[Musique]
dans le cadre de la visite à la réunion
du haut-commissaire à l'emploi Thibault
Guy lui Béatrice président du
Département a assisté ce lundi 10
juillet à la visite du village bycéa un
partenariat est en cours d'études afin
que le département puisse accompagner le
club de La Réunion dans certaines
actions en faveur des entreprises
réelles
ce mardi 11 juillet le Haut Commissaire
à l'emploi s'est entretenu avec les
institutionnels à trois bassins autour
de l'expérimentation à la réunion de
France travail
dans l'expérimentation sur le territoire
de trois bassins et saint-leuves et
justement ça regroupe un peu toutes les
spécificités de la Réunion on est sur un
territoire qui est quand même
en
montagne où il y a des soucis
d'accompagnement parce que les gens sont
confrontés aux problèmes de la mobilité
de perdre d'enfants tous des freins pour
une insertion durable et donc on dira
que effectivement là on est dans le cas
concret de problèmes rencontrés à la
Réunion surtout pour les bénéficiaires
du RSA mais pas que et on est vraiment
dans le vif du sujet dans le cœur des
problèmes
auxquels tous les partenaires sont
associés
cette séquence a été suivie d'une
rencontre avec les bénéficiaires du RSA
en cours d'insertion dont des publics
AirPlus un dispositif lancé à
l'initiative du département à l'issue de
la recentralisation par l'état du RSA en
actuellement j'ai commencé une formation
en DCG à distance et en DCG c'est
diplôme de comptabilité
donc j'ai eu un offre d'emploi au début
de mai avec une société de construction
donc je suis à mi-temps avec eux et
quand je bénéficier du RSA donc comme je
vais commencer l'emploi donc je vais
vous laisser de gagner un petit peu plus
sachant que j'étais à mi-temps donc
justement le R+ me permet d'avoir un
complément de salaire parce que en
mi-temps je paye pas beaucoup et ça me
permet aussi également de continuer ma
formation à distance en étant justement
salarié de l'entreprise ce qui ressort
c'est que vous savez on parle des
bénéficiaires du RSA mais d'ailleurs les
bénéficiaires du RSA il n'y a pas une
situation qui est équivalente chaque
parcours et singulier chaque situation
est singulière ça c'est la première des
choses et donc du coup notre
responsabilité au département à la
région à l'état un emploi c'est d'avoir
cette approche personnalisée ensuite
c'est du sur mesure vous voyez c'est du
sur mesure pour un grand nombre de
personnes mais chaque situation est
unique la deuxième chose c'est que la
vie peut réserver parfois des
difficultés des épreuves vous savez la
fragilité c'est consubstantiel à la
nature humaine et donc c'est important
qu'on prenne en compte aussi les
difficultés personnelles qui peuvent
être traversées et vu beaucoup de mamans
par exemple qui sont seuls avec des
enfants après des difficultés familiales
bien c'est comment vous allez les
accompagner les aider à régler un
problème de mobilité de garde d'enfant
si ils ont pas pu avoir un diplôme bah
c'est comment on va investir dans la
formation pour pouvoir le faire et donc
cette fragilité là il faut que la
société soit plus à des coûts de ça pour
faciliter le rebond cueillez une vraie
deuxième chance et c'est ça en fait
l'objectif de l'accompagnement rénové du
RSA c'est que le RSA ne soit pas une fin
en soi mais que ce soit vraiment un
moment de rebond de deuxième chance pour
pouvoir préparer un nouvel avenir et
donc c'est ça moi que je retiens et puis
la troisième chose c'est que ben je j'ai
vu derrière ces parcours là de la
volonté de la détermination de la fierté
retrouvée
la matinée s'est poursuivie par la
visite de la Mission Locale de l'Ouest à
Savannah pour une rencontre avec des
jeunes j'osais dit tout est venu
partager son expérience à l'Académie des
dalons
ça m'a aidé aussi de prendre la parole
au public donc à l'époque où je suis
arrivé à l'Académie des dalon est
possible de faire une interview comme ça
et puis voilà donc de me poser
professionnellement et même
personnellement que la cagnotte c'est se
poser
être bien de se faire accompagner dans
le côté professionnel parce que
généralement qu'on soit du lycée ou du
collège on est un peu perdu on sait pas
vraiment quoi faire mais là l'Académie
va vous accompagner va vous conseiller
et voilà c'est une très belle expérience
à vous en fait le département a fait du
soutien à la jeunesse une de ses
priorités à travers trois axes
accompagné le futur citoyen faciliter
l'accès des jeunes au droit et les
accompagner vers l'insertion le
département ce qui fait aujourd'hui
c'est de proposer justement un grand
public large de dans le territoire
l'accompagnement des jeunes avec
notamment l'Académie des dalons on a
aussi une association que le département
cofinance qui est le Cnam pour la
mobilité en hexagone et nous avons aussi
une expérimentation qui permet aux
jeunes de trouver une voie d'insertion
une voie professionnelle et nous
accompagnons ces jeunes notamment dans
leur parcours puisque à l'heure arrivée
que ce soit à l'Académie des Danon au
CNAM ou sur la CP nous avons des jeunes
qui sont un peu qui ont besoin
d'orientation et qui ont besoin
d'accompagnement et aussi de se trouver
trouver une estime de soi donc la valeur
humaine aussi est ajoutée dans cette
dispositifs du département pour finir la
délégation s'est rendu un atelier
chantier d'insertion au port un sapotis
à symboliquement été planté
[Musique]